this time limit
oh duder will want to celebrate his
birthday on a high that's for sure and
okay the game has started liam starts
with the white pieces he pushes his pawn
forward in the center it's a queen spawn
opening we'll see okay we don't see the
queen's gambit instead we see the
queen's indian uh which means black
pushing this pawn forward getting ready
to bring the black bishop out and fianca
to it as we see on its longest diagonal
and uh okay a trade of knights very
early on this is not the most common way
of handling the opening for black but
it's a solid choice by duda already
forcing them to think and this trade of
bishops
is normally a precursor to black just
trying to lock things down and kind of
curl up into a ball white's bishop
coming out black star squad bishop is
likely to do the same develop itself and
uh yeah stable start to this game simon
yeah yeah pretty pretty solid start i
mean as you say black's knight moving to
the center is not completely normal
this is the petrosian variation of the
queen's indian uh named after the great
world champion petrosian who like
little moves like this one on the side
which stops black stops your opponent
doing the things he wants to do um and i
think this will be quite a long game
here uh white generally should always
have an advantage because he has these
two strong pawns but apart from that
black is very solid and can develop with
ease
so early start at the moment and black
hole this is a little surprise actually
moving the bishop there i i do recommend
this in in the dutch setup actually to
go in for this move but it does
unbalance the situation yes i think some
spice yeah i mean also i think duder is
sharing his flexibility here because
he's using an idea that is often
used like when white plays the london
system which involves developing the
bishop to the square that liam did
and meanwhile liam just dropping his
bishop back he's happy to allow a bishop
trade but on his terms okay first dude
goes for a really ambitious really
controversial trade there he takes off
the white knight so now white does have
the bishop pair also some lines have
opened up towards the black king so
white's pawn structure is not ideal
white has doubled pawns there but an
open line towards the black king could
lead to danger later on really risky
what he's doing i mean
i mean just look at it bishop takes
bishop and after that lock the pawn
structure down get the bishop to the
long diagonal and uh well only white
will be using the open g line yeah a
weird pawn structure for both sides both
sides have double doubled pawns now
centralizing their rooks there the one
downside for liam is the white king i'm
not sure where he's going to put it
maybe he will castle over to the
kingside at some point uh he doesn't
really have a safe long-term home
meanwhile the black knight is very
flexible in positions with odd pawn
structures when double pawns exist you
nearly always want a knight rather than
a bishop so i'm less pessimistic about
black's chances but this last move
we love to see it pushing pawns
launching them up the board towards the
black king yeah
always
black now uh i'm probably probably
trying to concentrate his forces on the
half open file um maybe he's going to
swing his queen even two squares across
and get the other rook over there um i
mean it seems quite blocked as well you
might say that favors the knight of
block position but white's bishop is is
a very useful piece and a good piece
there
and look at look at that pawn look at it
go
go johnny go go go it's not really
johnny is it it's harry
yeah we're getting the song in
eventually it's going to be annie said
in the podcast the rapid fire questions
that he liked those uh cartoon songs and
he mentioned frozen yeah let it go yeah
yeah and uh yeah he didn't like baby
sharks so much i did
and i sang baby shark for the rest of
the day after hearing that no that's a
terrible song yeah exactly simon we're
gonna google it simon later
is it baby of those songs that was just
going to stick in my head now yeah so
when i go to sleep i just be like oh no
what have you done to me just like also
so today we sang the birthday song for
duda
but we did have a suggestion to say
everybody sing a song
thank you
that one also gets stuck to your head
anyways chess yeah talking of duda he
really has some questions to answer now
because look at this pawn it's marauding
up the board liam really trying to
create some holes around the black king
no matter what you do now whether you
capture this pawn this white pawn is
going to be super strong if you take it
off the board you open up lines for the
black king if you just bypass this pawn
and not allow any captures there then
there will be holes white's queen will
try and snake her way in later
so risky to allow the opening of the h
file is is
incredibly brave or risky so yeah i mean
i'm surprised by that i thought he'd
lock it down but he hasn't but maybe it
works yeah i mean look at that rook move
that he's playing you know note that he
didn't capture that white pawn sitting
there on g7 the black king is using that
pawn as a shield
and instead
all the firepower is going to be
happening along the sea line yeah and
liam he actually made a facial
expression there liam he just looked off
to the side as if he missed this last
move maybe he thought white was winning
but as you guys mentioned that white
pawn in front of the black king it's a
double agent white doesn't even want it
on the board
because now it just protects that black
king if the white queen comes out
attacking the black king then the black
rook is just a great defender so very
exciting position and of course black
has all this counter play on the queen
side so uh
which we're going to see now if black
just recaptures that pawn uh with his
rook um so um i i'm balanced incredibly
unbalanced a very wild position and liam
did have to take a time out to deal with
that strong black pawn
i'm surprised dude is thinking now i
guess he can choose which pawn to take
black's two rooks each of them can
choose to grab one of the white pawns
can he also just uh put some pressure in
the center
and you know pile on i'm just thinking
of advancing the central pawn two
squares yeah black's d-pawn can much
forward if you look at the c file where
black's queen black's rook are they are
pinning this white pawn so you could
definitely imagine black throwing things
forward first he takes away that double
agent the double agent is gone uh but
black gains a bit of time against
white's bishop i wasn't sure about that
i mean that pawn could have been taken
whenever wherever to quote shakira but
um
i like it
how many songs can we get in this one
meanwhile the reason i didn't like this
one and the evaluation bar reacting in
white's favor is because this move
white's bishop suddenly protects
everything
looks counterintuitive for treating all
of white's pieces pretty much on their
starting squares apart from one white
rook but looking good for white white's
pawn structure now very nice
in the center
this one could still go either way and
uh time scramble imminent both sides
around the two-minute 40 mark
okay
this is such a high quality game so far
wow yeah uh it's yet to be seen how duda
tries to break through to that white
king still on its starting square
yeah i think either of those pieces of
moves right the white king sweden the
queen the king the bishop the rook
yep that will listen yeah as if they
haven't moved exactly but he's actually
doing okay so this is the new way to
play
put your pieces back where they start so
you know he's doing all the work
basically now the pawns are doing the
heavy lifting they're carrying this game
for liam right now but at some point
later the white bishop will spring to
life the white rooks that decently
placed white queen despite starting on
her original square she has a lot of
potential on both sides of the board
duda i want to say doo dah now but dude
he's uh yeah he's thinking for one
minute in this position
okay well this is an interesting move
he's trying to get some squares for his
knight in the center but
as you mentioned white's pawns are are
so dangerously placed here and uh can do
to get his knight into the middle i mean
who's king is weak as this is this is
really important when the time control
gets uh gets shorter i mean
i remember malcolm payne um english
international master he wants to check
wow this wow this is this is incredible
chess
you know out of all the pieces that
could have chosen to develop
centralizes the king which is a
fantastic move because potentially you
know it gets ready to connect the rooks
i really i really like it for white now
because everything's coming over to
attack the black king afian chateau
brooke just to finish the thing that
malcolm said he said this is the best
defensive piece you can get but it's
only one piece um so yeah white white
looking good here david you think
looking very very good and that white
king move in front of the white queen
it's really reminiscent of van faris's
genius move earlier uh in the tournament
a few days ago
so yeah really counterintuitive but the
white king's safe for now protected by
its bishop
the thing for black is how is he ever
going to fight on either color complex
white's bishop controls the light
squares anywhere the knight jumps in it
will just get captured by the white
bishop and white's pawns completely
dominate the dark square so look at this
white's queen jumping out now as well
and you're right simon that black rook
in front of the black king if it gets
traded off the black king is in big big
trouble
so uh yeah it's hard to imagine the
black queen jumping into anywhere active
yeah
i mean one sided now
maybe black needs to go queen to try to
get it out on the dark square to check
the king somehow and he's gone for it so
he's moved his queen here with the idea
of moving the rook and then getting the
queen towards white's king this is the
only uh only counterplay i could see so
slow plan but better than no plan at all
right yeah for duda and another king
move yeah king steps out of that idea
yeah definitely and parks itself on a
light square and still the idea of
trading off the all-important rook on
the g line is in operation and uh you
know i really dislike that uh capture
you know capturing the g7 pawn
all the way back i thought was the wrong
pawn to capture i think duda just missed
the idea that white could re-route the
white bishop and
suddenly white has complete control and
liam what i love about him and the
reason he's so good at blitz is he keeps
things simple he plays complicated moves
but they cut out all calculation uh they
just cut out any of the opponent's plans
and right now big time advantage as well
for liam he's got double the amount of
time of duda he's playing very well
isn't he in this game i mean uh
everything's everything sort of uh
keeping control is so important
now at least for now yeah i mean in a
blitz game anything is possible uh black
can still jump in at some point uh that
wouldn't surprise me if black won this
game even but it's white who seems to be
under having the control he just needs
to get those rooks lined up black's got
quite a good defense on the king's side
it's going to be very hard to break down
but it is black who's defending and
that's the thing right now white has
complete control but queen and knight
together we've seen it so many times on
the tour if black's queen and knight can
combine and break into the white
position then anything can happen and
now look at this dude is trying to break
out he's trying to break through trade
off some pawns open up the black queen
okay liam with this last move losing a
little bit of control maybe i'm not sure
what the white queen's doing out there
on the side of the board she's gonna
zoom up and start to attack the knight i
think easy to defend though i just okay
she does attack uh this black knight and
up to dude now how is he going to
proceed is he going to trade one set of
rooks at some point is he just going to
defend his night now with his rook
really in the balance i think yeah
because uh the white king you know i'm
not i'm not sure which king is weaker
i'm actually thinking that black king is
so well defended by black's pieces i
don't see how you attack it the white
king
the black queen can get near it can come
down yeah you know
anything's possible black knight can
jump into the center now okay we did see
a rook trade very quickly i just grabbed
the pawn what
does that work well there's a draw here
if white wants to draw he has a false
draw but does he have something to
come down and give check yeah if white
wants a draw he will take the black
knight off the board with the white
queen the white rook will disappear but
then the white queen will be able to
give a lot of checks and that's why that
game would end in a draw but if liam
wants to win he won't take the black
knight now he'll move the white rook so
the white rook if it moves it means liam
wants to win this game 45 seconds for
him maybe he can bring his rook up to
the top of the board as you guys
mentioned yeah but really complicated
position here it could still go either
way wow looks good for liam but
he's playing for the win playing going
for the win nice and i have to say a
little bit of a surprising result in the
other first blitz game geary mamjarov a
draw because i've seen the bar been all
the way over to giri's side in that game
but it is a draw
it looks like he just uh missed his
chance he had a big big attack on
ishkiri but couldn't break through great
defense from mama jaroff meanwhile back
to this one and black's rook defends its
knight but suddenly
it feels like as long as you can find a
safe square for the white king which is
no given wow then you might be doing
well okay
that's a alpha zero move i remember like
bringing the queen back to come to the
other side of the board uh black getting
the check in first so maybe to stop that
but look at the time they're so short of
time keep an eye on that one yeah dude
it down to around 10 seconds liam around
20 seconds this one's queen this queen
is dancing around queen has done a lot
of exercise in this game using both
corners of the board we're trying to
find out okay but the a pawn is going to
drop what is black's threat i mean black
wants to bring the knight in to attack
the white king but can you ignore your
timing
okay he pushes his pawn that is not the
kind of move he wants to play black's
knight now will act as a defender but
duda wanted to go on the attack and now
liam whoa nice move attacking the black
queen and where's she going she has to
retreat
feels like it's so close to winning now
for liam if he can break through and
attack that black king how does he do it
okay well he's played it the night now
comes he said black is now trying to
attack as well that night threatening to
jump in he could still go either
weightless yeah i'm so brave ignoring
the white king and the threats to it
going for the black queen now
centralizing a second there's a big
check on the board that's a massive
check and uh oh he's got the queen he
has pinned the queen to the king that is
the end oh
that is the end so a win for liam leaden
and the first